wie gesagt jetzt werden hier noch einige
abschließende Beratung ohne Aussprache
durchgeführt aber dann soll es gleich
weitergehen mit der aktuellen Stunde und
da können wir schon mal drauf schauen
denn es ist in der letzten Zeit viel
schon debattiert worden
bundesinnenministerin Nancy fazer möchte
die Einbürgerung
erleichtern die Koalition möchte
insgesamt
ja die Migrationspolitik verändern sie
hat einen großwechsel angekündigt und
nun ist eben schon bekannt geworden was
sich die Innenministerin darunter
vorstellt sie möchte dass
zuwandererin und Zuwanderer schneller
eingebürgert werden nach
fünf Jahren soll es schon möglich sein
die deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft zu
erhalten wenn man sich fünf Jahre in
Deutschland rechtmäßig aufgehalten hat
momentan geht das erst ab 8 Jahren und
weil besonderen
Integrationsleistungen soll das auch
schon nach drei Jahren möglich sein
außerdem gibt es noch andere Ideen zum
Beispiel dass in Deutschland geborene
Kinder ausländischer Eltern automatisch
die deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft erhalten
wenn ein Elternteil von ihnen seit mehr
als fünf Jahren sich rechtmäßig in
Deutschland auffällt und ein
unbefristetes Aufenthaltsrecht erhält
kritik gibt's von der Union und das wird
jetzt hier Andrea Lindholz in nochmal
erläutern stellvertretender
Fraktionsvorsitzende der Unionsfraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren Anfang dieser Woche hat
die Bundesregierung ein weiteres Kapitel
ihres Buches mit dem Titel
unabgestimmte Alleingänge in der Ampel
aufgeschlagen Frau Feser und Herr Scholz
haben ihre Pläne für eine Reform des
Staatsangehörigkeitsrechts vorgestellt
und prompt kam Widerspruch von der FDP
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren bei einem
so wichtigen Thema sollte man
verantwortungsvolle sensibler und
professioneller vorgehen denn wir wissen
doch welche Debatten zu diesem Thema
schon in diesem Hause geführt wurden und
wenn und wie sensibel auch die
Bevölkerung zu Recht bei diesen Themen
reagiert denn die Staatsbürgerschaft ist
das zentrale rechtliche Band das den
Bürger mit seinem Staat und ein Stück
weit auch mit uns allen verbindet
aber nun zur Sache künftig will die
Ampel also die doppelte
Staatsangehörigkeit generell ermöglichen
mir ist zunächst folgendes wichtig wir
von der Union freuen uns grundsätzlich
über jeden der seit längerer Zeit in
unserem Land lebt der sich erfolgreich
integriert hat der hier eine Heimat
gefunden hat und der dann auch deutscher
werden möchte
ich bin aber der Überzeugung dass jemand
der Staatsangehörige der Staatsbürger
unseres Landes werden will in der Regel
seine alte Staatsbürgerschaft abgeben
sollte und nur in begründeten Fällen und
das ist die geltende Rechtslage sollen
davon Ausnahmen geben soll es davon
Ausnahmen geben das gilt etwa für
Staatsangehörige aus EU-Ländern weil wir
mit Ihnen eine gemeinsame Werte und
Rechtsordnung teilen und es gibt auch
andere europäische Länder die dieses
regelausnahmeverhältnis kennen die
generelle doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft
sie führt auch zu Loyalitätskonflikten
ich will Ihnen nur zwei Beispiele nennen
finden Sie liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der Ampel es wirklich gut
wenn zum Beispiel deutsche
Kriegsdienst für ein anderes Land
leisten ist es nicht besser wenn
Staatsbürger aus autokratisch regierten
Staaten ihre Staatsbürgerschaft aufgeben
und sich damit auch ganz klar für unser
demokratisches System entscheiden müssen
ich glaube nicht dass die doppelte
Staatsbürgerschaft die zentrale Lösung
unseres Arbeitskräftemangels darstellt
es braucht dafür andere Lösungen es
braucht gute Strukturen in unserem
Landes braucht finanzielle Anreize und
ein generelles zulassen der doppelten
Staatsbürgerschaft wird den
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt in
unserem Land nicht stärken sondern
Schwächen
und genau das gilt auch für den zweiten
zentralen Punkt ihrer
staatsbürgerschaftsreform sie wollen die
Fristen wie lange jemand in Deutschland
vor der Einbürgerung gelebt haben muss
nahezu halbieren Ausländer sollen
künftig statt nach acht Jahren schon
nach fünf Jahren eingebürgert werden und
bei besonderen Integrationsleistungen
schon nach Stadt nach sechs Jahren schon
nach drei Jahren
so kurze Fristen widersprechen unserem
unserer Sicht aus unserer Sicht im
Prinzip dass die Einbürgerung das
erfolgreiche Ende eines
Integrationsprozesses sein sollte und
nicht an dessen Anfang stehen darf und
sie verletzten das Prinzip von fördern
und fördern
Integration liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen braucht Zeit und sie sollte
nachhaltig sein sie sollte am Ende mit
der Einbürgerung belohnt werden und
selbst Schweden liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der Ampelkoalition dass sie
uns jahrelang als modernes und
fortschrittliches Land in der
einwanderungs- und Einbürgerungspolitik
als Vorbild verkauft haben genau dieses
Land ist sowohl restriktiver geworden
bei seiner Einwanderungspolitik und als
Antwort auf erhebliche gesellschaftliche
Spannungen prüft dort nun eine
Regierungskommission die
einbürgerungsfrist von bislang fünf auf
mindestens acht Jahre zu verlängern
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
auch an dieser Stelle sollte man genau
nach Schweden schauen wenn man hier in
Deutschland weitere Vorschläge
unterbreitet
wir sollten in diesen Zeiten vorsichtig
sein wir sollten unser Land und die
Menschen nicht überfordern ihr
Gesetzentwurf wenn er denn vorliegt den
werden wir genau prüfen wir werden ihn
genau analysieren denn es gibt noch viel
mehr Punkte zu klären als nur die beiden
von mir angesprochenen
allein schon die Halbierung der
Aufenthaltszeiten ist kein Punkt den wir
so mitgehen können aber wir werden Ihren
Antrag und ihren Gesetzentwurf wenn sie
sich denn einig werden ganz genau prüfen
und dann auch dazu noch mal Stellung
beziehen vielen Dank
für die Bundesregierung hat das Wort die
Staatsministerin Bremen alibali Radovan
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen gut dass es
dieser aktuelle Stunde gibt dann können
wir noch einmal aufräumen Liebe Union
mit ihren Märchen und Mythen die richtig
gefährlich für unseren Zusammenhalt sind
gerade erst recht in diesen Zeiten
ihre Worte in der Union
mit dem Pass um sich werfen Black Friday
Sonderangebot sozialtourismus was ist
das für eine Sprache unsere Agenda
Respekt für Lebensleistung Zugehörigkeit
zu unserem Land und endlich besser
schneller und mehr einbürgern darum geht
es liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der Kanzler und ich haben am Montag
einige der Menschen getroffen um die es
geht die sich eingebürgert haben die das
jetzt Vorhaben oder andere dabei
unterstützen wir trafen Frauen nur
Männer die unser Land voranbringen und
deren Eltern und Großeltern das auch
schon getan haben auch dank ihnen sind
wir ein starkes Land in der Mitte
Europas denken sie eigentlich auch an
diese Menschen wenn sie mit diesen
Worten um sich schmeißen das ist ein
Schlag in die Gesichter von 22 Millionen
Menschen mit familiärer
Einwanderungsgeschichte die hier ihre
Heimat haben mehr als die Hälfte davon
mit doppelten Pass und so viele
Kolleginnen und Kollegen dieses diesen
Hohen Hauses die ebenfalls eingebürgert
sind auch in ihrer Fraktion Liebe Union
die interessanterweise bei dieser
Debatte nicht dabei sind
wie so viele
wie so viele mussten auch meine Eltern
lange und hart dafür kämpfen und ich
sage sehr bewusst an dieser Stelle
stoppen Sie die Respektlosigkeit kommen
sie in der Lebensrealität unseres Landes
an
denn seien wir doch ehrlich die deutsche
Integrationspolitik hatte immer
Verspätung beim einbürgern beim
teilhaben vieles hätten wir schon vor
Jahrzehnten gebrauchen können aber jetzt
packen wir das endlich an wir bringen
unser Einwanderungsland auf die Höhe der
Zeit mit einer Koalition des Aufbruchs
und des Fortschritts mit einer Mehrheit
in diesem Hause mit einer
Bundesregierung die es ernst meint
drei Punkte worum es uns bei der Reform
geht erstens mehr Respekt wir wollen
Lebens- und Integrationsleistungen
anerkennen mit kürzeren Fristen mit
weniger Hürden und dir Hingabe von
Mehrstaatlichkeit warum sollte nicht
jemand deutsche oder Deutscher sein der
hier fünf Jahre rechtmäßig lebt sein
Lebensunterhalt sichert die Sprache
spricht und sich zum Grundgesetz bekennt
hier wird von einigen so getan als sei
das im Vergleich viel zu kurz dabei ist
es in vielen Ländern längst Normalität
warum sollten wir Menschen so viel
länger hinhalten als in Kanada
Frankreich oder die USA das war und ist
nicht klug einbürgern dass es kein
Gnadenakt kein veranschen kein
pulverfaktor liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
einbürgern
einbürgern das ist das gute Recht vom
Menschen die sich hier einbringen wir
wollen das modernste einbürgerungsrecht
der Welt dafür steht diese Reform liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
zweitens mehr Demokratie wer viele Jahre
hier lebt der soll neben allen Pflichten
auch alle Rechte haben unsere Demokratie
lebt von der Möglichkeit mit zu
bestimmen zu wählen und gewählt zu
werden es ist nicht gut wenn
Einwohnerschaft und wahlfolg immer
weiter auseinanderfallen und es kann uns
nicht zufriedenstellen
es kann uns nicht zufriedenstellen dass
wir im letzten Jahr mit
132.000 Einbürgerung nur 2,5 Prozent
beim einbürgerungspotenzial ausschöpfen
darum verbessern wir jetzt dem Weg zur
Einbürgerung wollen wir stärker um die
Menschen werden darum werde ich auch
eine
einbürgerungskampagne auf den Weg
bringen
und drittens mehrfachkräfte für mehr
Wohlstand es geht um die
Zukunftsfähigkeit unseres Landes
deutschland muss sich anstrengen im
Wettbewerb um die klügsten Köpfe es ist
ein Mythos das alle Schlange stehen und
darauf warten hierher zu kommen und in
Deli da kam und Dallas wird unsere
debattenklima sehr aufmerksam verfolgt
veranschen kommt da gar nicht gut an
weder hier noch dort
nein wir müssen hart dafür arbeiten
das Fachkräfte zu uns einwandern und
bleiben wir brauchen Sie dafür haben wir
gestern im Kabinett die Eckpunkte für
ein modernes Einwanderungsrecht
beschlossen klar ist wer kommt der soll
sein Talent voll einbringen unsere
Wirtschaft voranbringen und auch
deutsche oder deutscher werden wenn die
Voraussetzungen erfüllt sind dass es
eine bleibekultur die wir brauchen das
gehen wir jetzt gemeinsam in der
Ampelkoalition an vielen Dank
dr Gottfried Curio hat das Wort für die
AFD
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
die Voraussetzungen für den Erwerb der
deutschen Staatsbürgerschaft werden
komplett geschleift
Integrationsanforderungen runter sprach
Beherrschung runter staatsbürgerliche
Grundkenntnisse Fristen fast halbiert
dabei ist die Gemeinde Zielgruppe weder
ökonomisch noch kulturell irgendwie
integriert gerade das ist aber leider
der Grund die Anforderungen zu
Aufenthalt zu Staatsbürgerschaft immer
wieder abzusenken überproportional bei
sozialhilfeempfang bei Kriminalität
bildungsversagen all diese Probleme der
Zuwanderer sollen mit einem Handstreich
vertuscht werden in dem deren Zahlen in
die deutsche Gesamtbevölkerung
eingemeindet werden dabei wollen laut
einer Umfrage zwei Drittel der Deutschen
keine Vereinfachung der Einbürgerung
aber mit Brecht fragt sich die Regierung
wer es nicht am einfachsten man löste
das Volk auf und wählte ein anderes die
Ampel macht damit jetzt ernst sie will
endgültig Fakten schaffen und mit denen
seit 2015 importierten und alimentierten
Ausländern auch endlich ihre Wahlen
Steuern schon nach fünf oder gar drei
Jahren bekommen Sie die
Staatsbürgerschaft der Sprach- und
Einbürgerungstest wird für die die schon
lange da sind mit deren
Deutschkenntnissen man offenbar lieber
nicht rechnen möchte einfach gestrichen
Einordnung in die deutsche
Lebensverhältnisse kein Thema mehr
islamische viel eher kein Problem aber
eine Islamisierung findet ja nicht statt
armes Deutschland meine Damen und Herren
Merkel hat 2015 gesät jetzt ist
Erntezeit wenn genügend Neubürger
geschaffen worden sind nimmt die
entmündung der deutschen Fahrt auf die
deutsche Wahlbevölkerung soll durch ein
Heer ausländischer Sozialhilfeempfänger
gesteuert werden erst wird die halbe
Welt her gelockt durch überhöhte
Sozialleistungen hier auf der tränenden
Schiene Flucht verkauft dann bekommen
alle unberechtigten die
Aufenthaltserlaubnis als Chance dann
rein per Zeitablauf den deutschen Pass
das ganze ist ein Staatsstreich in der
Werder Demographie meine Damen und
Herren
Ministerin ferser gibt vor bei den
passwollegeber ein starkes Bekenntnis zu
Deutschland ab sage JA zu freiheitlicher
Gesellschaft Grundgesetz und
Gleichberechtigung nein sagt er nicht er
nimmt vielmehr das Wahlrecht um das Land
zu verändern und als Zeichen das
ausführliche Integration gerade keine
Voraussetzung mehr ist dass vielmehr das
Wahlrecht jetzt schlicht kurzfristig
ersetzen werden kann ist das Ganze
förmlich ein
antiintegrationsgesetz meine Damen und
Herren dabei sollte er mit dem Wahlrecht
die Steuerung des Landes in die Hand
bekommt eigentlich ein Demokratie Profi
sein aber die Leute kommen aus einem
politkulturellen Umfeld dem unsere
Vorstellungen völlig fremd sind die
werden diese Ideen ganz sicher nicht in
fünf oder drei Jahren verinnerlichen
wenn überhaupt in Wahrheit muss es doch
umgekehrt sein erst muss eine wirkliche
Integration erfolgen auch als Bemühung
um die Staatsbürgerschaft nicht
umgekehrt ohne
Schweiß kein Preis sie verschleudern
erst den Pass an ungenügend integrierte
das ist ein Aufbauprogramm für
Parallelgesellschaften meine Damen und
Herren und dementsprechend können
irgendwelche Gründe für ein schnelleren
Erwerb der Staatsbürgerschaft auch
überhaupt nicht benannt werden jetzt
schnell einfach alle deutschen nennen zu
wollen zeugt nur von Missachtung des
eigenen von Identifikation mit der
Nation ihren Werten Geschichte Kultur
kein Wort im chorvertrag will man mit
einer Kampagne den Erwerb der
Staatsbürgerschaft extra bewerben
offenbar ist das Bedürfnis auf Seiten
der koop-parteien größer als bei den
eigentlichen Adressaten es geht um
vermutete Wählerstimmen für die eigene
Partei dafür soll das Schicksal
Deutschlands verramt werden
vaterlandslose Gesellen wie sie im Buch
stehen meine Damen und Herren der
Kanzler klagt 9 Millionen Bürger leben
und arbeiten hier ohne die
Staatsbürgerschaft die Wahrheit von
knapp 12 Millionen Arbeiten viereinhalb
aber nicht die Quantität geht fehlt auch
die Qualität eingebürgert werden sollte
doch der der über eine Identifikation
mit Deutschland verfügt was tut man
dafür man macht den Doppel zur Regel das
glatt im Gegenteil das meinte das
Grundgesetz nicht mit dem Staatsvolk
allererst als Ursprung und Träger der
Staatlichkeit der Nation diese Pläne
sind schlicht verfassungswidrig und die
FDP im Umfragetief die das im
chorvertrag schon abgelegt hat simuliert
jetzt plötzlich Bauchschmerzen aber nur
der Zeitpunkt passe nicht den Inhalt
finden die okay meine Damen und Herren
seit 2005 haben wir eine nette
Auswanderung der deutschen aber für
Zuwanderung wird getrommelt
Bevölkerungsaustausch pur der häufigste
Kommentar unter Artikeln zur
einwirkungsoffensive ist ich wandere aus
kein Wunder wenn einem das Land unter
den Füßen weggezogen werden soll aber
der Kanzler weiß zum berührendsten was
erlebt habe gehörten die
Einbürgerungsfeier war aller Argumente
in der Sache verfällt man auf so eine
schmunzette es wird einem übel wenn man
von so viel Ergriffenheit hört was es
schon bedeutet habe einen Brief zu
bekommen vom Bürgermeister sie sollten
sich überlegen die deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft zu wählen er meint
natürlich die SPD zu wählen fakt ist je
mehr Ausländer wandern und eingebürgert
werden desto mehr deutscher wandern aus
weil die Steuern zu hoch sind den Spaß
noch zu finanzieren das ganze ist ein
einziges Fachkräfte vertreibungsgesetz
das ist die Ampel für Ausländer aber
keiner muss sie wählen denn es gibt ja
noch die Alternative für deutsche ich
danke Ihnen
[Applaus]
der Kollege auch mit nuripur hat das
Wort für Bündnis 90 die Grünen super
Bündnis 90 die Grünen ist auch einer der
beiden Parteivorsitzenden
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
ich weiß nicht ob sich jemand noch einen
Vertrag von Aachen erinnert da ging es
um die Vertiefung der
deutsch-französischen Freundschaft die
AFD hat uns damals erzählt darüber wird
sich Deutschland auflösen ich weiß nicht
ob sich jemand erinnert an den Global
Compact von Migration wir werden alle
sterben haben sie gesagt nichts davon
ist passiert jetzt geht die nächste
Geschichte sie erzählen einfach den
Weltuntergang herbei wollen die Leute
verunsichern ich kann Ihnen versichern
die Deutschen sind zu schlau um auf
diesen Schwachsinn rein zu fallen
was
das ist nicht neu dass das die AFD macht
es nicht neu was aber neu und zu ich
gebe zu befremdliches ist das eine
Klaviatur dem bisschen ähnlich klingt
und ich hoffe dass es nur so klingt
jetzt von der Union an dieser Stelle
gerade auftaucht ich verstehe es nicht
ich verstehe es nicht wir erinnern uns
uns alle zumindest wir älteren erinnern
uns an der Sommermärchen 2006 in
Deutschland so viele Klischees über
unser Land sind beseitigt worden und
zwar im Bild dieses Landes draußen in
der Welt wir waren gastfreundschaftlich
wir waren modern wir waren weltoffen so
wie es dieses Land und so wird dieses
Land auch draußen gesehen und ich kann
nur davor warnen mit diesem Bild zu
spielen das wäre nicht verantwortlich
aber es geht nicht nur es geht nicht nur
ums Bild
es geht auch um gesellschaftlichen
Zusammenhalt und es geht um unsere
Wirtschaft und ich verstehe ernsthaft
nicht was was hier passiert sie reden ja
auch mit der mit der Wirtschaft wir
reden viel mit Unternehmerinnen
Unternehmern ich habe das Gefühl dass
vielleicht auch mal zugehört werden soll
ihrerseits an dieser Stelle wenn man mit
ihnen redet da gibt es drei Baustellen
es gibt drei Baustellen wo der Schuh
drückt es Struktur bei den
Energiepreisen ja der der die billigen
oder die kostengünstigen Erneuerbaren
sind nicht ausgebaut sondern blockiert
worden von der Uni und die letzten Jahre
wir bauen sie gerade aus es geht um
Rohstoffe und Lieferketten wir sind
einseitig abhängig wir diversifizieren
gerade mit großer Geschwindigkeit und es
geht um Arbeitskräfte das Fehlen an ganz
vielen Orten Arbeitskräfte und deshalb
macht diese Koalition Fachkräfte
Einwanderungsgesetz und das ist nicht
die einzige Lösung das wissen wir das
ist nicht das Thema aber wir machen
Fachkräfte Einwanderungsgesetz wir
machen ein Chancen Aufenthaltsgesetz und
damit ist auch da auf dem Arbeitsmarkt
darauf vorangeht und wir wachen die
Perspektive für diejenigen die im
internationalen Wettbewerb um die ersten
Köpfe schauen wo sie hin wollen auch für
auch besser für Deutschland das ist doch
das was wir gerade veranstalten die Blut
haben ist auch deswegen nicht
vorangekommen weil das dieser
Perspektive nicht gegeben hat sie machen
Identitätspolitik wir machen
Wirtschaftspolitik sie machen Populismus
wir machen Integrationsarbeit und so ist
die Arbeitsteilung in diesen Zeiten und
das ist bedauerlich
und die die Lautstärke lässt ein
vermuten dass es ja eigentlich um die
Zerrissenheit geht im Umgang mit dem
Erbe von Angela Merkel dafür kann das
Land aber nicht dann setzen sich
zusammen und überlegen was sie machen
sollen und ich bin dankbar und froh und
ich weiß dass es ein mutig ist ich habe
selber auch schon mal gegen meine eigene
Fraktion gestimmt aber wenn man schaut
wie viele Leute aus ihrer Fraktion die
nicht irgendwelche Leute sind die im
Kabinett Merkel gesessen haben und
andere und und auch andere gewichtige
Positionen in der Union vertreten haben
jetzt für unser Chancen offen hat
gesetzt stimmen wollen dann sieht man
doch dass es eigentlich um die inneren
Zerwürfnisse der Union geht dabei müssen
sie sehr dabei müssen sie ja gar nicht
aufhören
Rita Süßmuth hat die hat damals die
Kommission geleitet die gesagt hat wir
brauchen Punktesystem und dieses
Baustein Einwanderung ist ein asset beim
beim Standort Deutschland hören Sie doch
auf BDI BDR BHK oder die
Wirtschaftsweisen sie werden Ihnen alle
dasselbe sein aber ich will noch eine
Sache wirklich versuchen zu verstehen
ich verstehe diese Sache einfach
schlicht nicht wenn ihr von verarschen
gesprochen wird bei Leuten die nur
überhaupt in Frage kommen wenn sie ihren
lebensaufenthalt dir selber verdienen
können beispielsweise ich frage das
wirklich ich frage mich dass das einer
der nicht hier heute stehen könnte wenn
es die mehr Staatlichkeit in härtefallen
nicht geben könnte in diesem Land eine
Gesetzgebung die sie heute sagen die
wird doch reichen die sie damals im
übrigen komplett bekämpft haben aber ich
frage mich warum haben Leute weniger
Rechte wenn andere mehr Rechte haben das
ist doch das was sie hier so gerieren
sie zu führen hier eine leiterte das
macht aber überhaupt keinen Sinn das
macht einfach keinen Sinn das einzige
die Sie mir erklären kann ist eine
loyalitätsparanoia aber dahinter ist
halt einfach nicht diese
loyalitätsparanoia braucht es nicht ich
bitte wirklich wirklich flehendlich
darum lassen sie uns diese Debatten
lassen die Krisen sie zu groß dieses
Land hat immense Herausforderungen und
wir müssen an dieser Stelle
zusammenstehen und alles dafür tun um
nicht noch weiter zu spalten es ist so
dringend notwendig dass wir und dafür
strecken wir die Hand auch aus sachlich
und normal miteinander solche Debatten
führen rational und beispielsweise für
die Frage was ist gut für den
Arbeitsmarkt das sollten wir zusammen
tun im Wohle unseres Landes herzlichen
Dank
Vorsitzende von Bündnis 90 die Grünen
unter anderem mit einem Rückblick auf
die Arbeit von Rita süßmut die war von
2000 bis 2001 im Juli Vorsitzende der
unabhängigen Kommission Zuwanderung so
lange wird über dieses Thema schon
gestritten und davor ja auch schon
Janine Wissler ist am Pult auch sie ist
ein Parteivorsitzende allerdings der
linken und jetzt ihr Beitrag
sie sind Teil der Gesellschaft aber eben
nicht vollständig sie dürfen nicht
wählen und nicht zur Wahlen antreten
weil sie keine deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft haben ihr Leben wird
bestimmt durch politische Entscheidungen
an denen sie nicht durch Wahlen
mitwirken können vor 60 Jahren kamen die
ersten Gastarbeiter nach Deutschland
ihnen wurde das Wahlrecht vorenthalten
und auch die Anerkennung ihrer
Lebensleistung Deutschland ist ein
Einwanderungsland und diese Realität
muss ich endlich auch im Wahl und im
Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht widerspiegeln
im Jahr 1972 lag der Anteil der
Wahlberechtigten an der
Gesamtbevölkerung bei 91%. seitdem sinkt
der Anteil stetig 2021 lag ja nur noch
bei 73%. das ist ein Problem für die
Demokratie und hinter diesen Zahlen
stehen Menschen die ausgegrenzt werden
als Einwohner zweiter Klasse die
einbowlungsboote ist im europäischen
Vergleich niedrig denn eine Einbürgerung
ist mit vielen Hürden Kosten und
Zeitaufwand verbunden das schreckt viele
Menschen ab überhaupt einen Antrag zu
stellen und deshalb begrüßen wir dass
die bundesinnenministerin eine
Erleichterung von Einbürgerung
angekündigt hat wie er auch im
Koalitionsvertrag das aampel versprochen
wurde wer schon viele Jahre in
Deutschland lebt der soll nach fünf
statt bisher nach acht Jahren
eingebürgert werden können und die
doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft soll
einfacher werden gut so diese Reform ist
lange überfällig um allen dauerhaft hier
lebenden Menschen Partizipation zu
ermöglichen meine Damen und
und was macht die Union sie erklärt die
deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft werde
entwertet und verramscht wenn sie ohne
Leistung vergeben werden was ist das
denn für eine bekloppte Argumentation
wie kann denn etwas verrancht werden was
hunderttausende Menschen jedes Jahr ohne
jede Leistung und ohne eigenes Tun
bekommen nämlich nur durch Geburt weil
ihre Eltern zufällig Deutsche sind was
haben Sie denn für ihren deutschen Pass
geleistet Herr Merz genauso viel wie ich
nämlich gar nichts genauso wie die
meisten Deutschen
es ist reiner Zufall es ist
spermienlotterie in welchem Land und in
welcher Familie man geboren wird warum
sollte man also dieses Dokument und die
damit verbundenen Rechte so vielen
Menschen vorenthalten die genauso hier
geboren wurden die genauso hier leben
und arbeiten wie alle anderen
CDU und CSU Spalten die Menschen und sie
spielen sie gegeneinander aus als würde
auch nur irgendein deutscher irgendetwas
dadurch verlieren dass jemand anders
eingebürgert wird der Pass wird ja das
hat niemandem weggenommen nicht der Pass
wird entwertet sie entwerten Menschen
durch solche Debatten meine Damen und
Herren und ich erinnere mich gut an 1999
an Roland Koch an die Kampagne gegen die
doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft als Menschen
zum CDU Wahlkampfstand gekommen sind und
gefragt haben wo sie gegen Ausländer
unterschreiben können die CDU hat damals
ganz bewusst rassistische Vorteile
geführt und sie haben mit dieser
Kampagne großen Schaden angerichtet sie
haben das Klima vergiftet und viele
Menschen zutiefst verletzt
so bereitet man den Nährboden für Hass
und Gewalt auf Kosten derer die
alltäglich von Rassismus betroffen sind
und die Gefahr von rechts die wächst
doch die Morde des NSU Halle Hanau der
Mordan Walter Lübcke jeden alle paar
Tage brennt eine Flüchtlingsunterkunft
wer in einer solchen Situation gegen
Einwanderer polymisiert und Stimmung
macht der weiß doch ganz genau was er
tut und sie sprechen ganz im afd-slang
von der Einwanderung in Sozialsysteme
von sozialtourismus und einer
inflationären Vergabe von Hessen das ist
ein gefährlicher Unsinn und das ist ein
Schlag ins Gesicht der vielen Menschen
die in den letzten Jahrzehnten einen
wichtigen Beitrag zum Wohlstand dieses
Landes geleistet haben und an den hohen
einbürgerungshürden gescheitert sind
meine Damen und Herren
ich fordere die CDU
und die CSU und uns besondere die Hessen
CDU auf dringend auf nicht erneut eine
rassistische Kampagne zur
Staatsbürgerschaft zu führen und obwohl
sie bekanntermaßen Teil der
Ampelkoalition ist distanziert sich die
afdp jetzt auch von der geplanten Reform
wie schon beim Bürgergeld fungiert die
FDP als Verstärker von März und Söder
auf Kosten der Menschen die ausgegrenzte
diskriminiert werden ob aufgrund von
Armut oder ihrer Migrationsgeschichte
oder aufgrund von beidem die
angekündigten Erleichterung müssen
schnell umgesetzt werden sie müssen
barrierefrei sein und unabhängig vom
sozialen Status die zuständigen Behörden
müssen entsprechend ausgestattet werden
und wir werden alle Schritte
unterstützen die Menschen demokratische
Teilhabe ermöglichen lassen Sie mich zu
dem Schluss zum Schluss kurz zitieren
aus dem flüchtlingsgesprächen von
Berthold Brecht der Pass ist der edelste
Teil von einem Menschen er kommt auch
nicht auf so einfache Weise zustande wie
ein Mensch ein Mensch kann überall
zustande kommen auf die leichtsinnigste
Art und ohne gescheiten Grund aber ein
Pass niemals dafür wird er auch
anerkannt wenn er gut ist während ein
Mensch noch so gut sein kann und doch
nicht anerkannt wird für uns zählt der
Mensch
Janine Wissler endet mit einem
brech-zitat in dieser aktuellen Stunde
des Deutschen Bundestags die auf Antrag
der Unionsfraktion zustande gekommen ist
und in der es um Pläne der
Bundesregierung zur schnelleren
Einbürgerung geht da gab es
differenzierte Äußerungen zu unter
anderem aus den Rhein der FDP und unter
anderem von Konstantin Kuhle dem
stellvertretenden Fraktionsvorsitzenden
in unserem Land umsieht wenn man mit
Arbeitgebern wenn man mit Unternehmen
spricht dann merkt man sofort der Mangel
an Arbeitskräften er ist mit Händen
zugreifen und wir werden als alternde
Gesellschaft diesen Mangel an
Arbeitskräften nur in den Griff bekommen
wenn wir auf Einwanderung setzen das
sagen Ihnen alle Experten und das sagt
Ihnen auch die Wirtschaft selbst ich
will mal vortragen was der deutsche
Industrie und handelskammertag an diesem
Montag in dieser Woche in der wir diese
Debatte hier führen gegenüber der
Deutschen Presseagentur gesagt hat ich
zitiere viele Unternehmen setzen darauf
dass der Zug von Fachkräften aus
Drittstaaten erleichtert wird auch in
der aktuellen Krise ist der
Fachkräftemangel für die Unternehmen
nach den Energiekosten das zweitgrößte
Geschäftsrisiko Zitat Ende ich will
ihnen etwas sagen meine Damen und Herren
es ist ganz normal dass sich in einer
Koalition mit so unterschiedlichen
Partnern wie Grünen und SPD und FDP dass
sich die Leute da auch mal in die Wolle
kriegen aber wenn wir eine Verantwortung
haben wenn wir eine Verantwortung haben
nachdem nach 16 Jahren die Union nicht
mehr den Innenminister stellt dann ist
es den Mehltau in der deutschen
Einwanderungspolitik zu beseitigen und
ein Einwanderungsgesetz zu beschließen
dass diese Erwartungen erfüllt liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und dabei sind
wir doch auf einem guten Weg dabei sind
wir auf einem guten Weg wir haben
gestern im Kabinett Eckpunkte zur
Einwanderung aus Drittstaaten in den
Arbeitsmarkt beschlossen Erleichterung
für Menschen mit praktischen
Berufserfahrung eine Ausdehnung der Blue
Card einer Ausdehnung der
westbalkanregelung und die Einführung
einer chancenkarte mit Punktesystem nach
dem Vorbild erfolgreicher
Einwanderungsländer wie Kanada und
dieses Gesetz werden wir beschließen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der
Union sie werden es bekämpfen das können
sie machen aber dann seien sie auch so
offen und sagen dass sie damit Politik
gegen die Interessen der deutschen
Volkswirtschaft und gegen die Sicherung
des deutschen Wohlstands machen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Union
wir Freie Demokraten sind davon
überzeugt dass dieses
Einwanderungsgesetz eines der zentralen
Reformprojekte der Ampelkoalition ist
und deswegen muss dieses
Einwanderungsgesetz auch zügig
beschlossen werden und deswegen wäre es
verfehlt das Thema Einwanderung bereits
jetzt mit dem Thema Einbürgerung zu
vermengen denn unser Einwanderungsgesetz
es muss eingebettet sein in einen
migrationspolitisches Gesamtkonzept und
dieses migrationspolitische
Gesamtkonzept das lässt sich
zusammenfassen mit der Formel mehr
reguläre Migration weniger irregulären
Migration liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
denn wir in der Gesellschaft dauerhaft
die Akzeptanz für Migration und auch für
das neue Einwanderungsgesetz erhalten
wollen dann muss Einwanderung geordnet
und regelbasiert erfolgen und wir haben
dazu verschiedene Maßnahmen vereinbart
in der Koalition unter anderem die
Beschleunigung von Asylverfahren und
asylgerichtsverfahren die wir schon an
diesem Freitag beschließen werden steht
aber noch mehr im Koalitionsvertrag
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen steht
auch eine rückführungsoffensive im
Koalitionsvertrag und es steht der
Abschluss von migrationsabkommen mit den
hauptherkunftsstaaten im
Koalitionsvertrag und hier sage ich ganz
deutlich an die Adresse der
Bundesregierung muss mehr passieren
damit wir gesamtgesellschaftlich auch
die Akzeptanz für Migrationspolitik
erhalten werden
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen Teil des
migrationspolitischen Gesamtkonzepts der
Ampelkoalition ist auch eine Reform des
Staatsangehörigkeitsrechts denn wir
wollen dass Menschen die sich in
Deutschland integrieren schneller
deutsche Staatsangehörige werden können
zu den Kriterien für eine Einbürgerung
gehört schon heute dass die Menschen
ihren eigenen Lebensunterhalt sichern
können und an dieser Stelle darf und
wird es auch keinen Rabatt auf die
Verleihung der deutschen
Staatsangehörigkeit geben liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen aber es wäre
doch absurd wenn diese Generation an
politischen Verantwortungsträgern die
Fehler wiederholt die im Umgang mit den
Gastarbeitern in Deutschland gemacht
worden sind ich finde es würde los ich
finde es daneben dass die dritte
Generation der Gastarbeiter Nachkommen
die seit drei Generationen in diesem
Land Steuern zahlen immer noch keine
deutschen Staatsangehörigen sind und das
werden wir ändern liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
schon heute
schon heute behalten übrigens 60 Prozent
der Menschen die eingebürgert werden
ihren ursprünglichen Pass wir haben also
bereits eine Hinwendung zur
mehrstatigkeit zur Wahrheit gehört aber
auch dazu dass in traditionellen
erfolgreichen Einwanderungsländern wie
Kanada wie Australien Menschen schon
innerhalb kürzester Zeit nach wenigen
Generationen nicht mehr Mexikaner nicht
mehr Briten nicht mehr Inder sind
sondern ausschließlich Australier und
Kanadier und deswegen werbe ich auch
innerhalb der Opposition innerhalb der
Opposition und innerhalb der Koalition
dafür dass wir uns damit beschäftigen
wie sich auch die Einbürgerung einbetten
kann in einem Gesamtkonzept der
Migrationspolitik und wie Einwanderung
und Einbürgerung zusammen gedacht werden
können und ihr braucht vor allen Dingen
die richtige Reihenfolge liebe meine
Damen und Herren
ich komme zum Schluss und will einmal
sagen viele wissen das ja dass ich aus
Niedersachsen komme und wir hatten in
Niedersachsen mal einen tollen
Ministerpräsidenten namens David
McAllister der wird mit Alistar war
nicht nur deutscher Staatsbürger der
wird McAllister war auch britischer
Staatsbürger ich frage mich was hat die
cdu/csu-fraktion eigentlich gegen David
McAllister Herr Kollege willkommen zum
Ende bitte ein toller Ministerpräsident
war und ich finde dass das nichts mit
seiner Staatsangehörigkeit zu tun hat
und deswegen sage ich an die Adresse der
Union ich wünsche mir mehr nehmen alles
da und weniger Roland Koch Herr Kollege
Konstantin Kuhle mit einem interessanten
Beispiel aus der Praxis der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland war zu
doppelte Staatsbürgerschaften angeht das
ist ja hier auch ein großes Thema in
dieser Debatte ganz interessant noch
nebenbei das Vorhaben zum Thema
Einbürgerung ist bislang am wenigsten
vorangedienen in der ampelkorti
Koalition da gibt es lediglich in
Anführungszeichen bisher das Papier aus
dem Innenministerium alle anderen
Vorhaben rund um Migration und
zugewanderung sind schon wesentlich
weiter Thorsten frei CDU CSU-Fraktion
und
ja diese Bemerkung habe ich an exakt
diejenigen gerichtet die jetzt so
applaudieren weil wissen Sie wenn Sie
eine grundlegende Veränderung einen
Paradigmenwechsel im deutschen
Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht wollen dadurch
dass sie die Mehrstaatlichkeit generell
annehmen und hinnehmen dann können sie
das nicht machen ohne dass eine
öffentliche Debatte geführt wird dann
können sie nicht glauben dass wir
darüber nicht reden wollen sie führen
eine Debatte sie machen Vorschläge die
60 70 Prozent der Menschen in unserem
Land nicht wollen und wenn es so ist
dann müssen Sie diese Debatte mit uns
führen und sie dürfen sie nicht so
führen dass sie jeden der andere Meinung
ist als sie als spalterisch als
populistisch als rassistisch oder wie
auch immer abtun das ist keine ehrliche
Debatte und um ehrlich zu sein das ist
auch unterhalb ihres Niveaus
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich
glaube man muss einfach auch der
Klarheit wegen sagen wenn Sie
grundsätzlich die Mehrstaatlichkeit im
Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht hinnehmen
möchten dann hat es weitreichende
Änderungen dann hat es weitreichende
Änderungen nicht nur für die
Zusammensetzung des Staatsvolkes dann
hat es weitreichende Änderungen
beispielsweise für das für die
Aufenthaltstitel und das System dort
insgesamt denn wenn es nach fünf Jahren
die deutsche Staatsangehörigkeit geben
soll dann hat es natürlich Auswirkungen
beispielsweise auch auf die Frage wann
wird ein Daueraufenthaltsrecht gegeben
wann werden andere Aufenthaltstitel
erteilt das hat weitreichende
Konsequenzen und darüber muss man
miteinander diskutieren und Sie haben
beispielsweise Vorschläge gemacht für
ein chanceneinwanderungsgesetz wo es
letztlich darum geht dass Menschen die
abgelehnte Asylbewerber sind die seit
Jahren nicht aus unserem Land ausreißen
dass die letztlich auch noch für
prämiert werden wenn sie nicht dazu
beitragen über ihre Identität Auskunft
zu geben also es geht am Ende des Tages
auch darum dass der Rechtsstaat sich
selber ernst nimmt lassen Sie mich eines
noch mal ganz klar sagen natürlich ist
Deutschland ein Einwanderungsland und
deswegen finde ich darf man die Dinge
auch nicht durcheinander bringen wir
werden um Frauen und Männer aus allen
Teilen der Welt die unsere Werte teilen
die hier gemeinsame Ziele mit uns
verwirklichen möchten die hier arbeiten
möchten und ihr Glück finden möchten es
ist übrigens nicht so dass sie dafür die
Voraussetzungen erfunden hätten 2019
haben wir ein Fachkräfte
Einwanderungsgesetz gemacht ja und wenn
sie mal ehrlich sind wenn sie mal
ehrlich sind sind die Probleme dieses
Gesetzes nicht das Gesetz sondern das
Problem im Bereich der Fachkräfte
Einwanderung ist beispielsweise dass
unsere Konsulat Abteilungen ein Jahr
teilweise brauchen bis Termine genehmigt
werden und zum anderen auch die
Anerkennung von Berufsabschlüssen nicht
so funktioniert wie wir uns das
vorstellen könnten das sind die
tatsächlichen Probleme die man dabei
lösen muss und lassen sie mich zum
Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht eines sagen
die Staatsangehörigkeit führt letztlich
dazu dass Bürger untereinander in einer
ganz besonderen Verbindung stehen das
hat was mit Identifikation zu tun
darüber haben wir gesprochen und jetzt
ist es so der Staat führt und die
Staatsangehörigkeit des führt zu rechten
und das führt auch zu Verpflichtungen
und eine Staatsangehörigkeit zu haben
ist eine relativ einfache Angelegenheit
wenn der Staat im Gewand eines
Sozialstaates daherkommt im Gewand eines
demokratischen Rechtsstaates wenn er bei
konsular Angelegenheiten im Ausland
hilft aber der Staat kommt auch um
beispielsweise zu fordern dass er von
den Bürgern ja nicht nur das Steuern
bezahlt werden das Eigentum zur
Verfügung gestellt werden muss dass er
mit Menschenleben verteidigt werden muss
und deshalb ist es immer eine
gesamthafte Betrachtung die man hier
anstellen muss ich will ihnen eines
sagen es ist richtig die
einbürgerungsquote in Deutschland ist
nicht hoch aber so zu tun als ob die
Tatsache dass nicht jeder die doppelte
Staatsbürgerschaft haben kann heute das
Hindernis wäre ist schlicht falsch
schauen Sie sich mal in Europa um in den
Niederlanden haben wir eine vier bis
fünf Mal höhere einbürgerungsquote
tatsächlich gibt es dort aber faktisch
die doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft nicht
die gibt es übrigens auch nicht den
Ländern wie Dänemark und Österreich und
es führte zu auch in Litauen nicht diese
Länder haben keine Integrationsprobleme
wer hat Integrationsprobleme Länder wie
Großbritannien Frankreich und Schweden
die Länder die die doppelte
Staatsbürgerschaft haben das eine hängt
mit dem anderen zusammen sie bauen ein
Popanz auf das ist nicht richtig und
eines müssen sie sich gefallen lassen
man kann
Meinungen in der Demokratie vertreten
aber sie lassen andere Positionen nicht
zu sie sind noch nicht einmal bereit
ernsthaft zu reden ohne hier mit Polemik
um sich zu werfen
Thorsten Frey ist der erste
parlamentarische Geschäftsführer der
cdu/csu-fraktion und der erste Satz den
er gesagt hat vorhin bei in seinem
Beitrag war diese Debatte hat keinen
guten Ton und das hat die heftigen
Reaktion in der Ampelkoalition ausgelöst
bzw in deren rein nächster Redner in
dieser aktuellen Stunde des Bundestags
wird Mahmut Özdemir sein
Parlamentarischer Staatssekretär bei der
Bundesministerin des Innern und für
Heimat
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich glaube es
ist gut zu Halbzeit nach dieser Rede
befördern zu wollen dass wir in der
anstehenden Diskussion um die Reform des
staatsangehörigkeitsrechtes auf einer
Sache und Fachebene zu bleiben und auf
Basis der Fakten weiter zu unterhalten
aber eine Mahnung kann ich mir nicht
ersparen im Zusammenhang Wertungen wie
verramschen
in Zusammenhang mit dem
Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht also das was
unser Staatsvolk definiert und bildet zu
verwenden halte ich für schändlich und
es kommt aus der und es kommt aus der
gleichen Schublade wie sozialtourismus
und diese Schublade sollte man zulassen
die Fakten wir verlangen weiterhin ein
qualifiziertes Aufenthaltsrecht es sind
ein Bekenntnis zur freiheitlich
demokratischen Grundordnung des
Grundgesetzes und eine
loyalitätserklärung abzugeben Identität
und bestehende Staatsangehörigkeit
müssen geklärt sein der Lebensunterhalt
muss gesichert sein mündliche und
schriftliche Deutschkenntnisse müssen
durch eine Sprachprüfung belegt sein nur
hier machen wir eine gezielte Ausnahme
zu der ich gleich noch mal kommen werde
es müssen Kenntnisse der deutschen
rechts- und Gesellschaftsordnung
nachgewiesen sein und auch künftig darf
eine Einbürgerung bei Bestehen einer
mehr Ehe nicht vollzogen werden und auch
nicht wenn die Gleichberechtigung von
Mann und Frau nicht akzeptiert wird wir
ersetzen damit den unklaren Begriff der
Einordnung in die deutschen
Lebensverhältnisse durch klare Kriterien
Deutschland ist längst ein
Einwanderungsland geworden Ende 2021 da
helfe ich auch gerne mit Fakten lebten
rund 72,4 Millionen Menschen mit
deutscher und rund 10,7 Millionen mit
ausländischer Staatsangehörigkeit in
Deutschland von denen sich rund 5,7
Millionen Menschen bereits mehr oder
mindestens zehn Jahre in Deutschland
auffielen dieser zur Folge dass ein
zahlenmäßig bedeutender
Bevölkerungsteil der auf Dauer in
Deutschland lebt und hier seine Heimat
gefunden hat von Rechten und Pflichten
eines Bürgers gegenüber dem Staat
ausgeschlossen bleibt für den
Zusammenhalt in Deutschland ist aber
entscheidend
dass auch diejenigen die längst Teil
unserer Gesellschaft geworden sind
mitgestalten und mitentscheiden dürfen
dazu gehört vor allen Dingen die
politische Teilnahme durch das aktive
und passive Wahlrecht Rechte die mir
persönlich trotz meiner Geburt in
Deutschland ohne eine Einbürgerung
verwehrt geblieben werden
fakt ist dass Deutschland bei den
Einbürgerungen im Vergleich zu anderen
europäischen Staaten nicht gut dasteht
die durchschnittliche einbürgerungsrate
liegt nach der letzten Erhebung von
Eurosat deutlich unter dem Durchschnitt
der Europäischen Union unser Ziel ist es
die Missstände zu beseitigen die sich
teilweise schon über Jahrzehnte
aufgestaut haben auch teilweise unter
einer sehr
fragwürdigen bmi-führung wir können
nicht ein Rahmenbedingungen für die
Einbürgerung festhalten die heute
gesellschaftlich und politisch keine
Billigung mehr finden durch die Mehrheit
das hat die Bundestagswahl das hat die
Bundestagswahl sehr deutlich gezeigt
das ist das Ergebnis der Bundestagswahl
sie müssen auch mal gesellschaftliche
und politische Realitäten irgendwann
akzeptieren also ich sehe den
Phantomschmerz aber kann ich Ihnen auch
nicht mehr helfen der Erwerb der Erwerb
und die Annahme der deutschen
Staatsangehörigkeit ist das stärkste
Bekenntnis zu Deutschland denn wer
deutsche oder deutsche Staatsbürger
werden will sagt ja zu einem Leben in
einer freiheitlichen Gesellschaft zur
Achtung des Grundgesetzes zur
Rechtsstaatlichkeit und zur
Gleichberechtigung von Frauen und
Männern dieses Bekenntnis ist wichtiger
als die Frage ob jemand eine oder
mehrere Staatsangehörigkeiten besitzt
insofern verweise ich Sie darauf dass es
mehr Staatlichkeit heißt und nicht
doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft die
Verpflichtung zur Aufgabe
die Verpflichtung zur Aufgabe ihrer
herkunftsstaatsangehörigkeit stellt für
viele
einbürgerungsinteressierte ein Hindernis
da sie fühlen sich Deutschland zugehörig
wollen aber den Bezug zu ihrem
Herkunftsland nicht völlig verlieren der
Grundsatz zur Vermeidung der
Mehrstaatlichkeit entspricht schon seit
langem nicht mehr der tatsächlichen
Einbürgerungspraxis im Jahr 2021 hat die
mehrstarterquote bei den Einbürgerungen
nun schon 69 Prozent erreicht der
Grundsatz der Vermeidung von
Mehrstaatlichkeit ist damit schon lange
nicht mehr enorm sondern die Ausnahme
das sind die Fakten
wir werden deshalb wir werden deshalb
Mehrstaatlichkeit daher künftig generell
zulassen merken Sie sich bitte diesen
Begriff mit anderen Begriffen haben sie
eher Probleme dadurch wird auch die
dadurch wird auch die optionsregelung
beim geburtserverwerb vollständig
entfallen künftig werden alle in
Deutschland geborenen Kinder
ausländischer Eltern bei denen
mindestens ein Elternteil seit mehr als
fünf Jahren rechtmäßig und mit
unbefristeten Aufenthaltsrecht in
Deutschland lebt die deutsche
Staatsangehörigkeit und die
Staatsangehörigkeit ihrer Eltern
erhalten und vor allen Dingen dauerhaft
behalten sie müssen sich nicht mehr für
oder gegen
Eigenanteil oder einen Teil ihrer
Identität entscheiden und das ist längst
überfällig liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
eine schnellere Möglichkeit zur
Einbürgerung ist ein wesentliches
Element auch einer guten
einbürgerungskultur die Teilhabe an
Entscheidungen schafft Menschen mit
Einwanderungsgeschichte die ein
qualifiziertes Aufenthaltsrecht haben
sollen daher bereits nach fünf Jahren
die Möglichkeit haben auch eingebürgert
zu werden und ich frage warum sollten
diejenigen die hier bereits verwurzelt
sind alle Einbürgerungsvoraussetzungen
erfüllen auch weiter warten muss wer
zusätzliche Leistungen erbringt kann
diese vorenthaltsdauer auch noch mal
erheblich verkürzen bei der
Modernisierung unseres
staatsangehörigkeitsrechtes soll auch
die Lebensleistung der Angehörigen der
sogenannten Gastarbeitergeneration
berücksichtigt werden das ist die
Generation die wir bis heute auf den
Stuben der Ausländerämter verweisen wenn
Sie einen neuen Pass beantragen und ihre
Aufenthaltserlaubnis übertragen lassen
müssen wir schicken sie zu
ausländerämtern lassen sie wochenlang
lassen sie monatelang darauf warten dass
sie eigentlich eine Staatsleistung
bekommen die ihn schon längst angedeutet
hätte werden müssen
das ist auch eine Frage des Respektes
dass wir diesen Menschen auch diesen
notwendigen Respekt mit diesem Gesetz
zollen sie haben in der Vergangenheit
keine oder nur wenig
teilhabeangebote erhalten deshalb werden
wir für Sie bei der Einbürgerung
Erleichterung beim Sprachnachweis
schaffen und auch auf den einbürungstest
verzichten
diese einbürgerungserleichterung sollen
auch für alle Personen gelten die das
gesetzliche Renteneintrittsalter also
das 67 lebensjahr vollendet haben damit
auch Sie eine realistische Möglichkeit
zur Einbürgerung haben
mit der Hinnahme der Mehrstaatlichkeit
werden wir ein Paradigmenwechsel
Einleiten der längst überfällig ist
zugleich werden wir mit der
Modernisierung des
staatsangehörigkeitsrechtes die
Einbürgerung einfacher und attraktiver
machen die sind aber nicht die einzigen
Gründe warum wir ein moderneres
Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht schaffen
wollen wir müssen das
Staatsangehörigkeit auch recht
reformieren um Deutschland Zukunft
festzumachen wir haben es gerade in der
Debatte schon teilweise gehört die
Wirtschaft mahnt immer wieder an dass
der Fachkräftemangel ein wesentliches
Hemmnis für das weitere
Wirtschaftswachstum ist und damit den
Wohlstand auch in Deutschland gefährden
könnte dann ist es doch gut und vor
allem wichtig Deutschland für
ausländische Fachkräfte attraktiver zu
machen und hier haben wir bereits ein
Mosaikbild vorgezeichnet einzelne
Mosaiksteine haben wir bereits
eingesetzt das chancenaufenthaltsrecht
kommt wir werden mit dem Fachkräfte
Einwanderungsgesetz mit dem
Familiennachzug und mit dem
Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht weitere
Mosaiksteine in dieses Bild rein tanzen
und ich sage auch allen Kolleginnen und
Kollegen hier im Haus ein Mosaikbild
muss durch schnelle Vervollständigung
der kleinen Steine die da rein gehören
durch die vielen kleinen Diskussionen in
den einzelnen Gesetzen aber am Ende des
Tages zu einem stimmigen Gesamtbild
führen und dieses Gesamtbild werden wir
als ampelregierung auch sehr schnell
zeichnen und bilden
der schnelle
der schnelle und vor allem schnellere
Erwerb der deutschen Staatsangehörigkeit
und damit eine sichere Perspektive in
Deutschland kann ein weiterer wichtiger
Baustein sein um Fachkräfte zu
motivieren nach Deutschland zu kommen
bzw dauerhaft auch hier zu bleiben eine
Debatte oder Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht
das von Restaurants und Stimmungsmacher
allerdings geprägt ist wird eine moderne
Einwanderungsland nicht gerecht und
entspricht und entspricht auch nicht der
Meinung der politischen und
gesellschaftlichen Mehrheit die Reform
unsere staatsangehörigkeitsrechtes ist
eine große Chance unseren
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt zu
stärken und ich glaube um es mal etwas
poetisch vielleicht zu sagen nichts ist
stärker als eine Idee deren Zeit
gekommen ist mittlerweile gibt es auch
die entsprechenden Mehrheiten im
Deutschen Bundestag dazu so abgewandelt
mit Viktor go danke ich Ihnen für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit danke
Mahmut Özdemir als parlamentarischer
Staatssekretär bei der Bundesministerin
des inneren und für Heimat hat ja einen
Sachlichkeit appelliert in dieser
Debatte sich dann die eine und andere
Polemik Richtung Unionsfraktion doch
nicht ganz verkneifen können Irene
miavic Istanbul erste parlamentarische
Geschäftsführerin Bündnis 90 die Grünen
Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht bekommt ein
Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht das Menschen
eine bessere eine verbindlichere
Integrationsperspektive eröffnet den
demokratischen Erfordernissen Rechnung
trägt und auch gut für unsere Wirtschaft
ist wir haben ein strukturellen
Fachkräftemangel der unseren Wohlstand
und die wirtschaftliche
Leistungsfähigkeit bedroht und all das
müssen wir dringend angehen meine Damen
und Herren
die Welt verändert sich aber die
märzunion und das konnten wir in den
Beiträgen gerade eindrucksvoll wieder
hören irrlich dort irgendwo zwischen
Identitätspolitik Vorurteilen und
zündelnden narrativen hin und her und
damit schaden sie aber dem
image-deutschlands ganz massiv meine
Damen und Herren
da wird der deutsche Pass als Ramschware
bezeichnet vor einem Black Friday wird
gewarnt und sie lieber Thorsten frei sie
haben es jetzt gerade in ihrer Rede
nicht gesagt aber in ihrem Interview im
ZDF da durfte man ihn dabei zuhören wie
sie davon gesprochen haben die deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft dürfen nicht ich
zitiere ohne weitere Leistung verliehen
werden nun Herr frei was war eigentlich
genau ihre Leistung die sie zum
deutschen Staatsbürger befähigt hat das
mag sich für sie absurd anhören das mag
sich für sie vollständig absurd anhören
aber die gleiche Frage die gleiche Frage
stellen sie ja in diesem Debatten
Menschen die genauso wie sie hier
geboren und aufgewachsen sind und nein
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen sie
merken es ja vielleicht selber bei
Staatsbürgerschaft geht es eben nicht um
Leistung es geht um bestimmte
Voraussetzungen ja das ist richtig und
die hat Mahmut öste mir gerade
eindrucksvoll dargestellt wohin da die
Reise gehen soll aber vor allem geht es
um die Möglichkeit
gleichberechtigt zum Erfolg unseres
Gemeinwesens beizutragen und in diesem
Geist werden wir das
Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht novellieren
wir führen diese Debatten wer dazu
gehört und wer nicht ja schon seit
Jahrzehnten und es ist ehrlich gesagt
unerträglich dass Menschen die keinen
deutschen Pass haben sich hier ständig
beweisen und erklären müssen oder dass
Menschen mit zwei Staatsangehörigkeiten
die Loyalität zu unserem Land hier
abgesprochen wird und auch die Union war
in ihrer Integrationspolitik schon
einmal weiter und auch sie haben etliche
Leute in ihren eigenen Reihen die
eingebürgert wurden erstens fragt man
sich wo die heute eigentlich alle sind
wahrscheinlich ist es ertragen sie es
nicht Ihnen hier zuzuhören und jetzt
führen Sie die Debatte ja im Stil der
90er Jahre wie bei Koch und Kanter ja
wie erklären sie das eigentlich ihren
eigenen Leuten und
daran merkt man einfach dass sie nach 16
Jahren Angela Merkel einfach noch gar
keine haben wo gar keine Ahnung haben wo
in ihre Reise eigentlich gehen soll das
ist natürlich sehr bequem für Sie mit
einer ordentlichen Portion Populismus
ihre eigene Orientierungslosigkeit
irgendwie zu überdenken aber genau
deshalb bin ich eigentlich sehr gespannt
was sie morgen bei der Abstimmung machen
werden wenn es um das Chancen
Aufenthaltsrecht geht da können sie ja
mal zeigen ob sie auf die Wirtschaft
hören und den dauerhaften Aufenthalt von
dringend gebrauchten Fachkräften
ermöglichen wollen oder ob Sie lieber
oder ob Sie lieber so wie jetzt hier in
die Debatte rechts abbiegen nein liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir reden hier
dauernd über amtliche Dokumente aber
dabei geht es um Menschen meine Damen
und Herren
es sind Menschen mit ihren persönlichen
Biografien mit ihren Familien mit ihren
individuellen Plänen ihr Leben zu
gestalten und Herr Merz hat gestern und
Morgenmagazin gesagt dass die die wir
hier haben wollen leider nicht kommen
tja da kann man sich ja mal fragen woran
das eigentlich liegt Herr frei hat sich
ja eben auch darüber beklagt dass die
Debatte hier keinen guten Ton hat ja das
teile ich ausdrücklich ja wenn wenn
diese Menschen sehen wenn diese Menschen
mitbekommen wie hier die Debatte geführt
wird und Worte wir haben schware hören
dann ist das ein Schlag ins Gesicht dann
fühlt man sich hier schlicht und
ergreifend unerwünscht und ich mache das
jetzt mal ganz persönlich auch ich wurde
eingebürgert als junger Mensch am
dritten oktober im Jahr 1983 als Kind
von Eltern aus dem ehemaligen
Jugoslawien die in den 60er Jahren nach
Deutschland gekommen sind und hier Leben
lang gearbeitet haben und wenn mein
Vater der als vorschlossen angestellt
war am Abend in die Kneipe gehen wollte
da war er sehr vertraut damit wenn es
hieß Gastarbeiter sind hier unerwünscht
und genau genommen waren noch nicht
einmal Gastarbeiter sondern hatte einen
ganz anderes Anstellungsverhältnis aber
das spielt hier gar keine Rolle denn es
geht um das was dahinter steckt wenn ich
heute an seine Erzählung zurückdenke ja
dann versetzt mir das immer noch ein
Stich ins Herz denn es muss endlich
Schluss sein damit Begriffe zu verwenden
die auf verletzende Weise andere
Menschen diskriminieren nur weil sie
eben nicht seit Generationen hier in
Deutschland leben ja und da sie von der
Union immer so gerne über Leistung
sprechen ja ich wünsche mir dass sie
explizit mal die Lebensleistung gerade
der älteren Generation würdigen die
wesentlich dazu beigetragen hat unser
Land nach der dunkelsten Zeit unserer
Geschichte wieder aufzubauen diese
Denkweise sollten wir endlich hinter uns
lassen meine Damen und Herren mit einem
neuen Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht
Deutschland ist ein Einwanderungsland
und es wird Zeit dass das Recht dieser
Tatsache endlich rechn trägt ganz
herzlichen Dank
Irene mich aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90
die Grünen mit Anmerkungen am Ende zu
ihrer Familiengeschichte einer
Zuwanderungsgeschichte auch die
Rednerinnen Liste in dieser Debatte
insgesamt gibt eigentlich auch schon ein
ganz schönen Querschnitt über die
Zuwanderungsgeschichte die jüngere
Zuwanderungsgeschichte der
Bundesrepublik Stefan thomey ist der
nächste Redner parlamentarischer
Geschäftsführer in der FDP-Fraktion
sind Teil eines
Gesamtkonzeptes eines Gesamtkunstwerkes
morgen wird der Deutsche Bundestag hier
ein Gesetz beschließen zu Beschleunigung
der Asyl und asylgerichtsverfahren weil
wir der Meinung sind dass diese zu lange
dauern sie dauern im Bundesschnitt
zurzeit über 26 Monate das ist zu lange
das wollen wir beschleunigen meine Damen
und Herren wir werden morgen ebenfalls
hier Bundestag ein Gesetz beschließen
zum Chancen Aufenthalt weil wir Probleme
aus der Vergangenheit lösen wollen dass
viele Menschen die jahrelang geduldet
sind und wegen dieser duldungsstatus
über lange Zeit im Sozialsystem kleben
bleiben nicht richtig vorankommen können
nicht integriert werden in unserer
arbeitsmarktsystem und damit entgehen
diesem Land viele viele viel zu viele
Chancen und das wollen wir ändern meine
Damen und Herren
das wird morgen geschehen und gestern
hat das Bundeskabinett Eckpunkte seinem
Gesetz zur Arbeitskräfte Einwanderung
mit einem Punktesystem beschlossen wie
es Kanada Australien Neuseeland kennen
wir wollen das zukünftig Einwanderung
gezielt und kontrolliert stattfinden
kann und auch das ist ein Teil unseres
Konzeptes
ein weiteres Projekt wird sein dass wir
Arbeitskräfte und deren Familien besser
bei uns integrieren auch das ist Teil
eines Gesamtkonzeptes meine Damen und
Herren und natürlich auch das ist ein
Teil der Wahrheit
können nicht alle kommen und es können
halt eben auch nicht alle bleiben
Integrationsförderung ist das eine was
wir wollen und was wir brauchen
Migrationskontrolle ist natürlich auch
das andere muss sich da ehrlich machen
nicht alle die Asyl bei uns beantragen
haben ein validen Asylgrund und nicht
alle die gerne bei uns arbeiten würden
bringen dafür die Voraussetzungen mit
deswegen brauchen wir auch
Migrationskontrolle und deswegen
brauchen wir auch eine konsequentere
Rückführung aber
aber wenn eine individuelle persönliche
Einwanderungsgeschichte gelingt wenn
jemand sich wirtschaftlich rechtlich
sprachlich kulturell gut bei uns
integriert und Teil unserer Gesellschaft
auf Dauer werden will dann ist es doch
eine positive eine gute Botschaft meine
Damen und Herren am Ende eines solchen
Weges und deswegen geht es nicht darum
deutsche Pässe zu verrauschen sondern es
geht darum Anreize zu setzen sich bei
uns zu integrieren Teil unserer
Gesellschaft und Landes werden zu wollen
und dafür geben wir ein
aufstiegsversprechen für alle die es
durch eigene Leistung in diesem Land zu
etwas bringen wollen und wir zeigen auch
wir moderieren das wir wertschätzen das
wir würdigen das indem wir schneller
eine Einwanderung Chance dafür gewähren
das ist unser Gesamtplan meine Damen und
Herren je mehr jemand beiträgt desto
schneller kann er auch bei uns ein
gebürt werden
und wir wollen auch eine großzügigere
mehrstaatlichkeitsregelung denn es kann
doch gute Gründe geben weshalb jemand
nicht die alte Staatsbürgerschaft gleich
ablegen kann oder will weshalb wir nicht
alle Bande zu alten Heimat durchtrennen
möchte weil ein Teil der Familie schon
hier lebt ein anderer Teil aber noch in
der alten Heimat lebt oder weil es
erbrechtliche oder andere Nachteile bei
der Ausbürgerung geben kann was wir aber
auch wollen ist dass wir uns nochmal
genau anschauen welche Konsequenzen es
haben kann wenn sich eine
Mehrstaatlichkeit über Generationen
immer weiter und weiter vererbt oder
nicht ein Generation Schnitt irgendwann
auch angebracht ist deswegen machen wir
ein echtes einwirken uns Angebot für
alle die bei uns bleiben und leben
wollen wir verlangen aber auch eine
gewisse Integrationsleistung das ist ein
Geben und Nehmen und das halte ich für
angemessen und angebracht und das sind
die Pläne der Bundesregierung zur
Einbürgerung meine Damen und Herren
Stefan thorme aus der FDP-Fraktion wo
parlamentarische Geschäftsführer ist der
nächste Redner in dieser Debatte Stefan
Heck sein aus der Unionsfraktion es
Mitglied im Ausschuss für Inneres und
Heimat
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren wir sprechen heute in
dieser aktuellen Stunde erneut über ein
wichtiges Thema Migrationspolitik ein
Politik fällt das nicht nur hier im
Deutschen Bundestag uns regelmäßig
beschäftigt sondern auch viele
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in unserem Land
und die Entscheidungen die wir hier als
Parlament treffen die unterscheiden sich
in einem ganz wesentlichen Punkt von
vielen anderen Beschlüssen die wir
erfassen Fehlentscheidungen in diesem
Bereich können meist nicht mehr
rückgängig gemacht werden und wenn
rechtssetzungen und Verwaltungshandeln
in diesem Bereich Erfolg haben sollen
dann müssen sie von drei Elementen
geprägt sein erstens eine notwendigen
Maß an Offenheit zweitens der Fähigkeit
zur tiefgründigen Differenzierung also
unterschiedliche Sachverhalte auch
unterschiedlich zu behandeln und
drittens der erforderlichen Konsequenz
und auch Härte bei der Durchsetzung
rechtsstaatlich getroffener Entscheidung
und
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren die
Bilanz ihrer Regierung nach knapp einem
Jahr im Amt in diesem Gesamtthema
Migrationspolitik ist verheerend die von
ihnen angekündigt und eben noch mal
angesprochene europäische Initiative zur
flüchtlingsverteilung ist schon nach
wenigen Wochen komplett gescheitert der
Zustrom an Schutzsuchenden ist heute so
groß wie nie zuvor und sie lassen
Bürgermeister und Landräte im Regen
stehen stattdessen wollen Sie
stattdessen wollen sie morgen im
Deutschen Bundestag ein Gesetz
beschließen dass nun auch denjenigen
Ausländern an Aufenthaltsrecht zukommen
lässt die ihre Identität bewusst
verschleiern von der versprochenen
abschiebe Initiative wir haben es ja
heute wieder gehört ist bislang nichts
übrig geblieben die Stelle des
abschiebebeauftragten die FDP meint es
immer wieder an ist immer noch unbesetzt
noch immer sind rund 300.000
ausreisepflichtigen in unserem Land
darunter auch Gefährder und Straftäter
als wäre das nicht genug wollen Sie nur
noch die Axt an unser bewährtes
Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht legen danach
soll der Doppelpass nicht länger die
Ausnahme bleiben sondern zu regelwerten
wir sind fest überzeugt das ist ein
fataler Irrweg und es ist sozialer
Sprengstoff für unser Land
[Applaus]
für uns als Union ist klar wer sich hier
gut integriert hat für die deutsche
Sprache erlernt hat und die notige
Wartezeit erfüllt hat der kann die
deutsche Staatsangehörigkeit beantragen
und dabei sollte es auch weiterhin
bleiben wir freuen uns über jeden der
sich zu unserem Land bekennt und das mit
einer Einbürgerung auch besiegeln will
für uns aber auch klar meine Damen und
Herren der deutsche Pass ist mehr als
ein Stück Papier steht am Ende und nicht
am Anfang der Integration
staatsbürgerliche
staatsbürgerliche Loyalität kann man
nicht einfach aufteilen zwischen zwei
Ländern in guten Zeiten Marktes kein
Problem sein in schweren Zeiten kann es
aber zu einer ganz erheblichen Belastung
für unsere Gesellschaft werden wir haben
eben über den Konflikt im Bereich des
Wehrdienstes schon gesprochen aber so
weit müssen wir ja gar nicht gehen
denken wir zurück an die groß angelegten
türkischen Demonstrationen zu
Unterstützung des türkischen Präsidenten
Erdogan in Köln und anderen solche
Städten da waren Menschen auf den
Straßen die sprichwörtlich mit der einen
Hand ihren deutschen Pass hochgehalten
haben sich auf die Versammlungsfreiheit
ein Grundrecht das erst einmal nur für
deutsche Geld zu berufen und mit der
anderen Hand türkische Fahnen geschwenkt
haben und für einen Regime geworben
haben von Erdogan dass all diese Rechte
die wir hier haben ignoriert und mit
Füßen tritt ist verwundert und ist
verwundert deshalb nicht dass die ganze
überragende Mehrheit der Deutschen diese
doppelpasspläne ablehnen aber das macht
auch deutlich ihre Pläne zum Doppelpass
sind falsch gefährlich und Sie müssen
dringend gestoppt werden
darüber hinaus hat die Bundesregierung
die vordere Aufenthaltsdauer in
Deutschland bis zur Einbürgerung vor
drastisch zu verkürzen wir sehen nicht
warum es einer solchen Änderung Bedarf
Handlungsbedarf gibt es gleichwohl und
zwar nicht in der Gesetzgebung sondern
im Verwaltungshandeln vor Ort und
deshalb wäre es gut gewesen Herr
nuripuri sprich sie mal an als
Frankfurter Abgeordneten es wäre gut
gewesen wenn sie als Verantwortliche der
Ampelkoalition vor diesen vollmundigen
Ankündigungen die wir hören mit ihren
kommunalen Vertretern vor Ort gesprochen
hätten in Frankfurt der größten Stadt
meines heimatbundeslandes Hessen der
fünf größten Stadt in Deutschland
regieren seit September SPD Grüne und
FDP gestern waren der Frankfurter Neuen
Presse zu lesen dass in der dortigen
Ausländerbehörde seit etlichen Monaten
sage und schreibe 15.000 schriftliche
Anfragen einfach unbeantwortet geblieben
sind seit Monaten teilweise seit Jahren
warten mehrere tausend tüchtige Menschen
darauf dass die Verlängerung ihres visas
oder ihres Visums oder ihre
Arbeitserlaubnis
vorgenommen wird eine große Deutsche
Bank hat letzte Woche einen hochrangigen
Mitarbeiter freistellen müssen da trotz
zahlreicher Nachfragen keine
Entscheidung der Frankfurter
Ausländerbehörde erfolgte daraufhin hat
die Bank Dienstaufsichtsbeschwerde gegen
die gesamte Ausländerbehörde eingelegt
ein bis dahin wohl einmaliger Vorgang
das sind Vorgänge die in ihrer
Verantwortung in Frankfurt Ampel
stattfinden meine Damen und Herren
und ich frage mich schon ich frage mich
schon was muss in diesen vielen tausend
Menschen vorgehen die in Frankfurt
darauf warten dass sie endlich einen
Termin bei ihrer Ausländerbehörde
bekommen seit Monaten teilweise seit
Jahren darauf warten und jetzt der
noripur von ihnen von Ihnen hier hören
müssen dass sie die Wartezeit gesetzlich
verkürzen wollen das muss doch wie
blanker hohen klingen für diese Menschen
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren ich
komme zum Schluss wir kennen bislang nur
die Eckpunkte dieses Gesetzes aber die
genügen schon zu erkennen das ist
Kollege völlig falsche Richtung geht die
Pläne sind spalterisch gefährlich für
unseren gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhang
sie sollten nachlegen noch ist es
wichtig wären zum Schluss gekommen
Stefan Heck war das er war von 19 bis 21
Staatssekretär im hessischen
Innenministerium und wir gucken mal als
Verweis auf den übernächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt auf die
Regierungsbank der sitzt nämlich
Franziska Brandner Parlamentarische
Staatssekretärin eben Ministerium beim
Bundeswirtschaftsminister ziemlich
eingemummelt und das mummelt und das
geht mir die Gelegenheit die noch mal zu
sagen dass sie Temperatur hier im
Plenarsaal des Deutschen Bundestags auch
nicht mehr über 19 Grad geheizt wird
also da muss man sich schon mal ganz gut
einpacken und dann ist es auch wenn man
länger da sitzt etwas frisch und
Franziska Brandner wird noch etwas
länger da sitzen müssen wir sind zurück
in der Aktuellen Stunde zum Thema
Einbürgerung und Migration und es
spricht Hakan demia aus der SPD-Fraktion
und uns selber sagen können wir haben in
den letzten vier Jahren
diese Gesellschaft weiter stärker
zusammengerückt
und ich frage mich ob das nach dieser
Debatte die ich jetzt heute gehört habe
spätestens nach dieser Debatte die
cdu/csu überhaupt so noch sagen kann
noch eine Sache und die stelle ich mir
wirklich
sie haben ja unter ihnen ja auch
Politikerinnen und Politiker mit
doppelter Staatsbürgerschaft
Politikerinnen und Politiker die
eingebürgert worden sind sie haben
wahrscheinlich auch Menschen die
eingebürgert worden sind und Sie gewählt
haben aber auch da spätestens nach
dieser Debatte
müsste man sich doch die Frage stellen
kann man diese Partei noch wählen oder
müsste man nicht aus dieser Partei sogar
austreten nach all dem was sie heute
gesagt haben
und die Differenzierung ja wir sind für
Differenzierung also sie haben aber hier
noch nichts differenziert sie könnten ja
sagen wir möchten nicht nach fünf Jahren
sondern sie könnten sagen wie ein San
Marino noch 25 Jahre aber das bringen
sie ja nicht rein sondern sie führen die
gleichen debatten wie vor 20 Jahren und
das ist offenbar das Verständnis von
konservativ sein
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen es ist
gut dass wir heute über die
Staatsangehörigkeit das über das
Staatsangehörigkeitsgesetz sprechen und
es wurde schon heute häufiger genannt
deshalb verstehe ich auch den Punkt mit
der
den Punkt nicht zu sagen wir vertrauen
den Menschen vielleicht bisschen weniger
weil sie den doppelten Pass haben 69
Prozent wenn wir uns das letzte Jahr
angucken 69% der Menschen haben die
doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft und das
funktioniert gut es funktioniert gut und
diese Debatte die wir heute führen
führen wir bei diesem 69% nicht warum
sollten wir es bei den restlichen 31%
führen liebe Freundinnen Freunde
[Applaus]
und heute geht es nicht nur darum dass
wir sagen
die voraufenthaltszeit geht von acht auf
fünf Jahre runter es geht auch nicht nur
um die doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft
sondern es geht darum wie können wir
auch die Demokratie im Land stärken
wollen wir das Menschen früher
mitbestimmen können gewählt werden
können selber wählen oder wollen wir
dass es später funktioniert und ich
glaube als Demokratin und Demokraten
muss es doch klar sein wenn wir die
Chance haben dass Menschen früher
mitbestimmen dürfen und können dann
sollten wir auch das Nutzen liebe
Freunde
[Applaus]
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
1999 ist meine Familie mit mir zusammen
gewechselt wir haben die deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft angenommen und einige
Jahre später konnten meine Eltern zum
ersten Mal wählen und ich kann mich noch
daran erinnern wie glücklich sie waren
und und ich kann mich noch daran
erinnern dass auch meine Mutter am
Infostand tatsächlich auch der SPD eine
Rose bekommen hat und sich gesehen und
anerkannt gefühlt hat und das kann
natürlich ein Dorn in ihrem in ihren
Augen sein zu sagen da sind jetzt
Menschen die vielleicht andere Parteien
wählen als sie jetzt möchten aber das
gehört auch zu deren Recht wir gehen mit
dieser neuen Reform diesen Weg weiter
und ich hoffe
dass wir nach der Legislatur alle hier
in den Spiegel schauen können und sagen
können wir haben es gemeinsam geschafft
dass dieses Land nach diesen vier Jahren
näher zusammengerückt ist das ist unser
Ziel auf jeden Fall und ich würde mich
freuen wenn Sie dieses Ziel auch haben
danke schön
[Applaus]
Matthias Helferich hat das Wort
und Matthias Helferich war mal in der
afd-fraktion jetzt ist der fraktionslos
im Bundeskanzler Scholz hat Recht wenn
er feststellt ich zitiere eine
Demokratie lebt von der Möglichkeit mit
zu bestimmen so entsteht Legitimität so
wächst die Akzeptanz staatliche
Entscheidung es ist
demokratietheoretisch ein Unding das
Millionen Menschen in Deutschland leben
die nicht demokratisch partizipieren
können die gebotene Antwort ist es aber
nun gerade nicht diese Menschen mit der
deutschen Staatsbürgerschaft
auszustatten sondern Deutschland endlich
vor dem Austausch seines Souveräns zu
schützen es bedeutet den Abschied von
uns selbst wenn sie die deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft zum reinen
Berechtigungsschein diskreditieren wie
ist der Staatsrechtler Peter Graf
klimansek erklärte die Demokratie
benötigt wie ein Tränke klar stellte die
gemeinsame Sprache kulturbewusstsein
Tradition Abstammung gleiche
verfassungsvorstellungen als
gedeihensvoraussetzung ihr Angriff auf
unserer Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht die
Herabwürdigung unseres Volkes auf ein
Nebeneinander von Parallelgesellschaften
die Regierung des Volkes als
Schicksalsgemeinschaft wird das selbst
von Historikern als demokratiefeindlich
bewertet werden und es ist ja zu
begrüßen wenn Migranten in der deutschen
Kultur aufgehen aber seien wir doch mal
ehrlich wer will es den Millionen
türkischen doppelpassinhabern eigentlich
verübeln sich weiter als Türken in
unserem Land zu führen das Volk als
organische Einheit braucht
identitätsstiftenwerte und auch ein
Mythos pubertätsblocker für Kinder
Regenbogenfahnen gratismut und morbide
selbstauflösungsromantik sind eben nicht
attraktiv die Aufweichung unsere
Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht die Auflösung
unserer Identität als Land der Deutschen
sind ja im Kontext ihrer Agenda
konsequent das ist ja alles konsequent
und folgt einem großen Plan für jene die
aber trotzdem unserer Verfassung stehen
ist das ebenso konsequent gegen ihre
ersetzungsligation den großen Austausch
des Souveränität aufzubegehren der
zentrale Begriff der Demokratie ist eben
das Volk und nicht die Menschheit folgen
Sie lieber Karl Schmidt und stimmen Sie
gegen jede weitere Liberalisierung des
Staatsbürgerschaftsrechts vielen Dank
[Applaus]
christian jüksel hat jetzt das Wort für
die SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren auf den
Tribünen
können Sie sich vorstellen bei der
Abstimmung zum neuen
Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht nicht mit
Stimmen zu dürfen ich weiß wie sich das
anfühlt denn ich war viele Jahre von
demokratischen Wahlen ausgeschlossen als
ich das erste Mal in meinem Leben wählen
durfte war schon Mitte 30 zu diesem
Zeitpunkt habe ich bereits 28 Jahre in
Deutschland gelebt hier gearbeitet und
mich auch ehrenamtlich engagiert
Deutschland war längst zu meiner Heimat
geworden aber ohne die deutsche
Staatsangehörigkeit gehörte ich
rechtlich nicht dazu
können Sie auf der rechten Seite zuhören
vielleicht können Sie auch noch mal was
dazu lernen ja dann gehen sie raus das
ist vielleicht viel besser
das zeigte sich auch im Alltag die
Wohnungssuche scheiterte immer wieder
ich hatte sogar
ich darf alles sagen was ich möchte weil
ich bin deutsche Staatsbürgerin genauso
wie viele andere also hatten sie einfach
mal den Mund
also das zeigte sich auch im Alltag denn
die Wohnung suche scheiterte immer
wieder ich hatte sogar Probleme eine
Kfz-Versicherung zu finden nicht einmal
an Bürger entscheiden dürfte ich
teilnehmen es war daher ein sehr
emotionaler Moment ein unbeschreibliches
Gefühl dann das erste Mal meinen
deutschen Pass in den Händen zu halten
das erste Mal zu wählen und mit den
entscheiden zu dürfen das Gefühl Teil
dieses Landes zu sein es wird daher Zeit
dass wir die Rahmenbedingungen endlich
an die Lebenswirklichkeiten anpassen
wir als Ampelkoalition packen das mit
dem neuen Staatsangehörigkeitsgesetz an
wie erleichtern den Weg zu deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft gerade auch für die
Menschen die schon längst
selbstverständlich Teil dieser
Gesellschaft sind dazu verhelfen wir
nicht nur zu einer schnelleren
Einbürgerung und damit zu schneller und
Integration wir ermöglichen auch die
Mehrstaatlichkeit für bestimmte
Herkunftsländer ist das übrigens heute
schon in Deutschland Normalfall aber
eben nicht für alle so kann aktuell ein
EU-Bürger eine EU-Bürgerin oder ein
Bürger aus der Schweiz seinen Pass
behalten
wären zum Beispiel eine Bürgerin oder
ein Bürger aus der Türkei ihn abgeben
muss nach unserer Reform wird die
Mehrstaatlichkeit außerdem für deutsche
gelten die nach Erwerb einer weiteren
Staatsangehörigkeit im Ausland ihren
Pass nicht mehr verlieren werden eine
Einbürgerung EU-Ausland dürfen deutlich
Deutschland dürfen deutsche übrigens
schon jetzt ihren Pass behalten viele
dieser deutschen ausgewanderten werden
sicher verstehen dass ein Pass eben
nicht nur ein Stück Papier ist sondern
mit einem Gefühl und einer Identität
verbunden ist
das neue Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht wird
auch die Hürden für die einbürger der
Gastarbeitergeneration senken denn die
Gastarbeiterinnen und Gastarbeiter haben
Deutschland zum Wohlstand verholfen ihre
Lebensleistung wollen wir hiermit
wertschätzen und anerkennen
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren der
Union entgegen ihrer Darstellung und
bleiben die zentralen
einbürgerungskriterien natürlich
weiterhin erhalten wie etwa der
Sprachnachweis oder die Saison des
Lebens und Haltes wenn sie jetzt in der
CDU und CSU trotzdem davon sprechen dass
die Staatsangehörigkeit verrampscht oder
entwertet würde dann ist das wirklich
verletzend ist ihre deutsche
staatsangeht ist ihre deutsche Identität
weniger wert seitdem auch ich den
deutschen Pass besitze oder wird ihr
passt zusammen Schwangere wenn ich Ihnen
sage dass ich eine doppelte
Staatsbürgerschaft habe mit ihrer
Wortwahl legen Sie genau das nahe und
das ist einfach unerträglich
wie wichtig ist übrigens diese Debatte
ist zeigt auch ein Blick in ihren Reihen
sie haben die Aktuelle Stunde
Beantragung schauen Sie mal wie viele
von ihren Kollegen Kollegen dort sitzen
liebe Kollegen Kollegen meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren der deutsche
Pass ist wertvoll wer könnte das besser
wissen als die Menschen die ihn nicht
per Geburt sondern ihn per Einbürgerung
erhalten haben aber nicht nur der
deutsche Pass ist wertvoll auch die
Menschen die sich um den Pass bemühen
wertvoll für unser Land sind zum
Beispiel die Türkei stämmigen
wertvoll für dieses Land war mein Vater
der mit so vielen Gastarbeitern und
Gastarbeitern das Wirtschaftswunder in
diesem Land erst möglich machte und
wertvoll sind die Migrantinnen und
Migranten die auch heute zusammen mit
ihren deutschen Kolleginnen und Kollegen
den Laden am Laufen halten ob an der
Supermarktkasse
als Lehrkraft oder am Krankenbett liebe
Kollegen und Kollegen
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
wir können froh sein wenn sie es
möglichst viele von ihnen für die
Einbürgerung entscheiden und aktiv das
gesellschaftliche Zusammenleben in
unserem Land Deutschland mitgestalten
können herzlichen Dank
güdigster aus der SPD-Fraktion war die
vorletzte Rednerin in dieser aktuellen
Stunde die auf Antrag der Unionsfraktion
stattfindet und in der es um die Pläne
der Koalition der Bundesregierung zu
einer schnelleren Einbürgerung geht
letzter Redner aus der SPD-Fraktion
einer der stellvertretenden Vorsitzenden
Dirk Wiese
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
Kolleginnen und Kollegen am Schluss der
Debatte gibt es einem noch mal die gute
Möglichkeit etwas zusammen zu fassen und
ich glaube wir haben heute zwei klare
Alternativen hier gesehen wir haben eine
Ampelkoalition die Fortschritt für
dieses Land will die dieses Land
voranbringen will die gerade im Bereich
der Einwanderungspolitik die Fenster
aufmachen will frischen Wind reinbringen
will die Lebensrealitäten anerkannte und
wir haben eine cdu/csu-fraktion die mit
Friedrich Merz zurück in die 50er Jahre
wird das ist die klare Alternative die
sich hier heute in dieser Debatte
gezeigt hat
und ich muss das schon sagen wenn ich
dir diese Debatte mir noch mal vom
Beginn des letzten Wochenendes bis jetzt
vor Augen führe die Union hat gemerkt
dass sie möglicherweise ein Thema
erkannt hat sie wollte polemisieren sie
wollte dieses Thema nutzen vielleicht
zum parteipolitischen Vorteil was
passiert denn dann diese Woche innerhalb
der Union wird diskutiert 26 oder 24
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Union sagen
beim Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht naja das
was die Ampel davor schließt ist doch
mal Sonne gar nicht so eine schlechte
Idee und wir machen mal ein offenes
einen Brief und sagen das ist gut
zustimmen wollen wir noch nicht aber
enthalten und das ist ja auch schon mal
ein Zeichen an sich das ist der eine
Punkt dann redet Stefan Heck gerade hier
am Pult und hält eine Rede lieber
Kollege Heck die ich vorsichtig
formuliere etwas für Fragwürdigkeit
halte in dem Moment wo sie hier diese
Rede halten äußert sich der hessische
Ministerpräsident auf dem Ticker der
hessische Ministerpräsident kritisiert
die eigene Partei für beleidigende und
verunglimpfende Rhetorik und ruft seine
eigene Partei zur Mäßigung auch Stefan
Heck nichts davon mitbekommen am zu den
sage dann sehen wir die Debatte so die
Union ruft dann diese aktuelle Stunde
auf und möchte natürlich mit dieser
aktuellen Stunde natürlich auch die
Ampelkoalition etwas vorführen das gibt
es manchmal im politischen Berlin ist
aber um es nochmal vorsichtig
auszudrücken etwas schief gegangen
Friedrich Merz erkennt dieselbe und hat
ungefähr für eine halbe Stunde die
Debatte verlassen das ist die
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion im 21
Jahrhundert und jetzt will ich mal ein
paar Punkte ansprechen ich meine das
muss man sich mal vor Augen führen da
wird jahrelang darüber geredet dass es
innerhalb der cdu/csu einen anderen Pack
gibt diesen andenpackt ich habe gesehen
dass da viele ältere Herrschaften der
Union drin sind ich habe gedacht den
gibt's gar nicht mehr diese Woche kommt
der anpackt wieder zum Leben und wenn
ihr sie die Woche richtig gut
abschließen wollen aber nennen sie
wahrscheinlich am Ende der Woche noch
Roland Koch zum migrationsbeauftragten
der scdu-bundesstation
und jetzt will ich mal auf die Punkte
eingehen worüber wir reden wir reden
über migrationspolitische Vorhaben der
Ampel die Lebensrealitäten in diesem
Land anerkennen und ich sage das auch
mal ganz deutlich da sind wir weiter als
sie und übrigens auch hier in deutschen
Bundestag es gibt so viele tolle
Kolleginnen und Kollegen hier in den
Fraktionen die die doppelte
Staatsbürgerschaft haben die bereichernd
sind für dieses Land und das gibt es
auch draußen in den Wahlkreisen und wir
brauchen doch auch gerade Fachkräfte wir
brauchen Arbeitskräfte wir brauchen
Zuwanderung das ist doch das was uns die
Wirtschaftsunternehmen immer wieder
sagen aber ihre Rhetorik die sie über
Jahre geführt haben die hat mit dazu
geführt dass Fachkräfte um die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland einen Bogen
machen wir sind unattraktiv für
Fachkräfte und ich sage Ihnen mal auf
woran das liegt das liegt an einem
Jürgen Rückers Kinder statt Inder das
sind Formulierungen die sind bei Ihnen
wieder aktuell auf der Tagesordnung gar
nicht zu sprechen es ist angesprochen
worden von der Kampagne gegen die
doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft in Hessen
und nicht würde es nicht überraschen mit
irgendein jetzt aus ihren Reihen auch
hier wieder auf die Idee kommt das
voranzubringen und ich sage das mal ganz
deutlich das was wir vorhaben dass wir
eine Fachkräfte einwanderungsstrategie
gestern vorgelegt haben das ist gut und
richtig und wir brauchen das auch da
muss fachkräftezuwanderung geregelt
werden und das was wir bisher haben
reicht jedenfalls nicht aus um die
Fachkräfte und Arbeitskräfte Lücke bei
uns im Land zu schließen das werden wir
auf den Weg bringen und genauso gut
werden wir morgen das Chancen
Aufenthaltsrecht auf den Weg bringen es
kann doch nicht sein dass Menschen die
jahrelang bei uns sind die hier in einem
duldungsstatus sind die oftmals auch
abgeschoben werden direkt von Ihrem
Arbeitsplatz die Kinder werden aus der
Schule geholt diesen Menschen müssen wir
doch eine Perspektive geben und dass wir
denen diese Perspektive morgen mit dem
Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht ermöglichen das
ist richtig und das ist eine gute
Entscheidung auch diese Ampel-Koalition
und dann komme ich noch mal zur
Staatsbürgerschaft und ich bin auch froh
ich hatte da diese Woche Kollege coole
einmal so ein Interview und Deutschland
gehört die war ein bisschen erstaunt
wäre der redet dann was der Kollege
durch ich bin ja froh dass wir heute die
Kurve recht haben aber auch bei diesem
Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht will ich doch
mal sagen die Anerkennung der doppelten
Staatsbürgerschaft dass wir das möglich
machen dass wir auch die Lebensleistung
der Gastarbeitergeneration anerkennen
die dieses Land mit aufgebaut haben das
ist doch richtig und auch die doppelte
Staatsbürgerschaft ist doch auch schon
Alltag in vielen Ländern Europas ist
Alltag bei vielen Menschen hier bei uns
im Land die einen doppelten Pass haben
und darum werden wir das gemeinsam
voranbringen wir als Ampelkoalition
wollen Fortschritt in diesem Land das
werden wir schaffen das werden wir
umsetzen und das tut der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland im 21 Jahrhundert gut vielen
Dank
Dirk Wiese war der letzte Redner in der
Aktuellen Stunde des Bundestags zum
Thema schneller Einbürgerung morgen
steht das Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht auf
der Agenda im Bundestag um 9 Uhr aber um
8:45 Uhr haben wir dazu schon zwei MdB
beide aus Berlin beide Generalsekretäre
ihrer Partei nämlich Kevin Kühnert und
Mario chaia im Interview das wollte ich
ihm jetzt schon mal ans Herz legen